the question is could we have something
that is substantially different from
what we do now should we and my answer
is sort of
I'm down on mart narcissism and not slow
down on vanity and the jury's out on
self-confidence and self-esteem because
it depends how much weight you've got if
you've got the right amount good for you
optimism is not a philosophy you need to
have if things are okay right optimism
is a philosophy that's on the table for
you if you want to get to someplace
better
you could almost write the story of
modernity of the modern period in terms
of the rubble of failed surrogates for
God that it contains threesome geist
science art and Michael Jackson if
Russia behaved in as lawless away as the
United States and Britain have behaved
over the last 20 years
the world would be entirely in flames
and not saying we couldn't have a
machine which could be conscious and
could perhaps achieve things of
intelligence that we can do I'm just
saying that they won't be computer
controlled devices
you